okay welcome back uh today we're going
to run through some of the lab for
chapter eight uh tree based methods uh
focusing on uh random Forest um and
boosting we're going to start off with a
single tree based method just to get a
sense of uh how that performs uh and
compare it to The Ensemble
methods okay as usual we have our some
imports at the beginning and then we
have some new Imports for this model
module I should say so um the main
methods we're going to talk about today
are uh random forest and boosting and
we're going to be doing regression so
that's why we're looking at random
forest regressor and greeting boost and
regressor instead of
classifier okay we'll also talk a little
bit about decision trees we'll look at
the decision Tre regressor and there's
the corresponding classifier decision
tree
classifier okay
so fitting a classification or
regression tree because well there
again methods from psyched learn they
will they will you know look almost
identical to the methods we saw in
chapter 4 for classification so once we
form a set of features and and and an
outcome we'll just use the fit fit and
predict method and similarly for cross
validation like we saw in chapter six
because it's an SK learn estimator we
can use the same kind of setup to do
classification so since we're going to
focus on regression for random forest
and boosting we're going to jump to the
part of fitting a regression decision
tree rather than a classification
decision
tree again they look diff similar the
main difference being one is a binary
outcome or categorical outcome and the
other one is a continuous
one okay the data set we're going to use
um for regression today is the Boston
data set we saw in chapter 3 um and the
pre-processing is pretty simple we just
have to find a set of features um and
we'll do that by making it Des design
Matrix as if we were doing linear
regression and just taking the design
Matrix though we don't want to include
an intercept so we're going to say
intercept equals false because the
regression trees fit their own intercept
and well it would be could be
problematic having uh an intercept
column in
there so regression trees we're going to
convert the design Matrix to an array
rather than a data frame so we lose some
of the um some of the feature names but
these are the this is the um preferred
data format for fitting the regression
tree okay
so for validation we're going to split
our data into training and test and fit
on the training and evaluate on the test
we've seen this
before to construct a to fit a
regression tree we first construct the
estimator and remember for pyed learn
the informing the estimator we give no
data in this argument we just sort of
specify the hyperparameters of the
method
once we have constructed the estimator
we call the fit function and after we
can call predict function to to predict
on new outcomes so one thing you know
slightly different about a tree is
people sometimes want to visualize what
a regression tree looks like so there's
this function plot tree that gives us a
visual representation of the tree and
you can see some measure of a fit in
each of the leaves the resolution of
this picture is not great um and from
also you can sort of trace an
observation down the regression tree
whoops let's see if I can zoom in on
this so if the number of rooms is less
than 6.8 we'll go to the left and then
the next variable check is lstat ETC and
that's how we how the predictions are
formed in a decision
tree so let's just um let's let's look
at the the the accuracy of fitting this
regression tree so just for reference
later we see for using a regression tree
we got about um mean squared error of
about 28 this mean squared error is for
the here quote the best regression tree
and what is best here
well we didn't I haven't mentioned it
yet but we we show how to do um the cost
comp cost complexity printing path in
this bit of code so we've optimized this
parameter on the training data to try
and um get a better estimator and this
is according to that metric the best
estimator found with the mean squ area
of about
28 this grid parameter we saw in chapter
six when we have a tuning parameter this
is a method a generic method in psyched
learn you can use to tune a
hyperparameter for an estimator right
this is our estimator regression we
specify some arguments to the the the
the reg estimator and then we vary that
over the grid to get this best parameter
so just to summarize the general
procedure is to grow a bigger tree and
then use cross validation to determine
how much to prune it back in this case
um and this was all done on the 70% of
the the data which was training data and
then this final estimate of error for
the the optimally prune tree is on the
30% of the data which is test data and
we saw it we see it 20 just over
28 okay so that's using this tuning this
way is is about as well as we could do
with the single
tree and we're going to move on to um to
Ensemble methods so the first Ensemble
method we'll talk about is bagging and
or random Forest remember the main
difference between bagging and random
Forest is random Forest randomly um has
some randomization injected in which
features are used for each tree but
remember the basic the basic scheme of
bagging is well what it's it's bagging
stands for boot shop aggregation so a
boot trop sample is taken from the data
that's a sample with replacement a tree
is fit to that bootstop sample and then
uh the final estimator is the average of
these uh these trees fit on each
bootstrap sample the random Forest adds
this wrinkle of um not using every
feature on every tree so along with
taking a random sample of the feature of
the of the rows of the data set the
cases we also take a random sample of
the features every time a split's taken
you take a sample of the features oh
yeah yes I and I'm sure there are
variations of this but yes okay
um so uh okay uh let's see so how do we
specify it well the random Forest is a
psyit learn estimator uh
so once we construct the the estimator
using RF this is our shorthand for
random Forest regressor um well we just
have to call the fit method on the
training data that is XT train and Y
train and then we can evaluate we can
predict on the test data and evaluate um
the accuracy that
way okay and note here I've put a an
argument random State equals zero
because this is a random procedure um
there is a random number generator
underlying this and setting the state
means that the results will be
reproducible so when we run this again
we'll get the same answer if you don't
specify a random State then the results
will change from run to
run okay so just with that simple
regressor we get a mean squared error um
of 14 that's about half that we had on a
single tree so we see that in terms of
predictive performance Ensemble methods
you know without very much effort really
out outdo a single tree very
easily so let's
look this is we've I've called this the
bag version of the tree and that's
because I've here I've put in this note
Max features is the number of columns of
XT train and that that um essentially
tells the uh random Force regressor to
use every feature when it does the split
so it doesn't do any sampling um uh of
features when it splits if we made this
smaller than the number of columns which
is 12 if we made it smaller then we
would it would be a random
forest and just a note for for py learn
the the default number of features used
for splits varies between the regressor
random forest and the classification
random Forest I think it's p the default
is is to do bagging for regression I
believe and square root of P or square
root of the numbers for
classification
okay so the another parameter you can
specify in the random Forest is the
number of trees grown the default is 100
we can here let's try increasing the
number of trees to 500 and see if we do
any better we didn't really do any
better it's about
14.6 um and of course What's Happening
Here is that we're averaging the S you
know independently drawn trees from the
same distribution given the data so at a
certain point averaging will kick in and
we will no no longer see any Improvement
but if we take too few trees like a
single tree um we will not achieve a as
high as good a mean Square air that as
low of me square
a okay so if we want to have something
more like a random Forest we can
decrease the number of features here we
set number of features equal to six
that's bigger than the square root of P
but
um it is this will give us some
selection of features for every split
and we see here that actually degrades
the performance a little bit uh it's 20
instead of um
14.6 one of the nice things about random
forests uh is that you can there's a
measure of importance for each feature
that you can use to sort of you know
post Hawk analyze which features seem to
be important in in producing these
predictions so remember these are um
this this measures the sort of average
Improvement gain but whenever we added a
split on Alat there's some improvement
in mean squared eror and this is the uh
in some sense the average improvement
over whenever we had done a split in any
of the trees so it's it's saying that
elad and a number of rooms are by far
the most important features and all the
rest seem to be much smaller in
comparison yes yeah yeah and then that's
you know if we think back to that plot
of our single tree elstat and room were
also the first few features we split on
so these seem to be important for ition
here
okay so the other Ensemble method that
we'll talk about is boosting and so if
you both boosting and random Forest use
a collection of trees uh the one the big
one of the big differences between
random forest and boosting is the type
of trees fit at each stage in random
Forest uh the the at each stage the the
the tree fit is of the the same as the
first stage because you know once we fix
the data a bootstrap sample at any given
time is is this bootst sample at stage
one is the same as the bootst sample
that's at at the 500th stage in boosting
what happens there's there there can be
resampling it depends on the
implementation but what changes as you
go through the the stages is the we're
fitting trees to the residual after
having removed some of the the effect of
the up to that point the the fitted the
fitted model
so there so Jonathan unlike in in random
Forest where once you fit enough trees
things don't change with boosting the
more trees you fit the more you're going
to start overfitting the data and so
there really is going to be a bias
variance trade-off in the number of
trees that's right and we'll see a plot
of that um coming up we as a as a as the
number of estimators that's the number
of trees grows we can plot both the the
test era and the training era and we'll
see um we'll see what com Trevor just
mentioned coming up but in terms of
fitting these models uh once we specify
the hyperparameters again since it's a
sklearn method it's we use the fit the
fit method um to predict to fit on
training data and we can predict on test
data so let's make that plot of um of
erir prediction of training error and
test error as a function of tree and to
do that we can use this this for the a
boosting estimator there's this thing
called stage predict which as its name
suggests uh it predicts in stages and
the stages are as we go through the the
trees fit in the boosting process so um
the residual changes and gets smaller as
the the the training residual gets
smaller as we go along the uh the stages
so the the the training error should go
down and at some point test error will
possibly go up so let's just look at the
plot
after 5,000 trees here uh we see
training error has sort of begun to
saturate um we didn't see here that a
increase in overfitting on this data set
but that doesn't mean that boosting will
never overfit it's just on this
particular data set um it has not it's
possible that we would see some uptick
and test error as we grow the number of
trees in this data set we do
not okay so now let's take a look at our
mean squared error on
the test data at the final stage and
it's about 14.5 which is you just
slightly better than random Forest but
they're very comparable here then the
bagging version the bagging version of
random Forest that's right okay yeah
yeah okay so the last um thing we can
talk about is there's just there are
other parameters and if you look at the
the help for gbr you'll see many
parameters you can set um one of the
being the learning rate and here we just
um changed the learning rate just for
for to show you that you can change
several things on on the boosting
estimator and actually in this case it
does not make a difference that doesn't
mean it will never make a difference but
there are a huge number of tuning effect
tuning parameters and I think some
implementation of boosting also do do
some resampling as well as they go along
so but the the general flavor of
boosting is fitting a tree to residual
compared to the general flavor random
forests which is fitting you know an
identical tree to some randomized
version of the data at every stage um
beyond that there are different details
uh in their
implementation okay we're not going to
um the final topic here is Basi and
additive regression trees we're not
going to go we're not going to we're not
going to talk about those and this is a
good place to to wrap up the love for
chapter eight thank
you